To prove their batteries are reliable in freezing
temperatures Canadian Tire built a truck out
of 11,000 pounds of ice.
And burrito box is the world's first burrito
kiosk that serves five different types of
burritos at the touch of a button.
Vsauce!
Kevin here - this is Mind Blow.
The SkyCycle is an urban concept that would
allow people to ride their bikes in the sky.
Developed by architect Sir Norman Foster it
would consist of 220 kilometers of safe car
free bike routes above London.
And include 200 different entry and exit points,
accommodate 12,000 cyclists per hour, and
improve bike travel time by almost 30 minutes.
Budgee is a robot designed to help with everyday
tasks and to carry your stuff around.
Created by Five Elements Robotics, it can
hold up to 50 lbs and collapses easily for
transportation with a 6-8 hour battery life.
It's intended for a wide range of uses from
helping the elderly and disabled to carrying
all of your stuff at an amusement park or
mall.
Sea Stars are able to see images with tiny
eyes located at the ends of their legs that
can be cut off and regenerate.
So Yeah.
Pavegen is making energy out of footsteps.
By transferring the kinetic energy from a
human's step into renewable electricity that
can be stored for future use.
The tiles are waterproof, durable, and made
from recycled materials so they can easily
cover existing high foot traffic areas.
Currently, their largest permanent installation
is at Kent grammar school where 24 kinetic
tiles cover over 5 meters of corridor.
A new adhesive activated by UV light is being
developed to repair holes in blood vessels
and the walls of the heart.
Until now medical adhesive glues were not
able to withstand the pressure that a beating
heart exerts and didn't adhere well to wet
tissue.
But by studying the viscous secretions of
slugs and sandcastle worms researchers were
able to figure out how to form stable bonds
underwater.
Corning Gorilla glass created the worlds first
antimicrobial cover glass for mobile devices.
It's formulated to protect touch surfaces
from the growth of algae, mold, mildew, fungi
and bacteria and works continually over the
entire life of the device.
Aurora is a headband that claims to let you
control your dreams.
It plays special lights and sounds while you're
in the REM cycle of sleep that are supposed
to induce lucid dreaming.
The software in the headband senses when you're
dreaming by measuring brainwave and eye movement
activity.
The user is able to pick out their own specific
dream signs, which are used to induce the
lucid dreaming by making you aware of your
surroundings.
It also sets a smart alarm clock that will
wake you during your most refreshed cycle
of sleep.
Mother monitors small connected sensors to
make your everyday routines easier.
Motion cookies can be attached to almost anything
including water bottles to check if you're
drinking enough water, toothbrushes to make
sure everyone is brushing or pill bottles
so you don't forget your medication.
Then Mother puts all of the information into
the sense board where you can then check out
the news of your daily life.
Onewheel is a self-balancing skateboard that
makes you feel like you're on a hoverboard.
It uses gyro and accelerometer sensors to
feed a processor that determines the exact
speed to drive the motor based on how you
lean your body and because of the self balancing
abilities they say almost anyone can learn
to use it within minutes.
The power lasts for 4-6 miles and can reach
up to 12 miles per hour.
MiP is a self-balancing robot that can be
controlled by hand gestures and/or your smart
device.
MiPs can dance, race, and battle each other.
They're taking Preorders now and plan to roll
out in the Spring of 2014.
Finally, The Waters of Greenstone by Nathan
Kaso shows the changing landscapes of New
Zealand over a three week period.
I'm gonna leave you with geometric bubbles.
And as always - thanks for watching.